we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P call me anytime here's a
teacher who called in during their lunch
break they have a student who seems to
have been the victim of serious uh
political disinformation my guess would
be from the parents take a listen to
this
hi David I teach fifth grade yeah in the
suburbs of Chicago Illinois and I needed
to call you I'm on my lunch break
because right before lunch one of my
students raised his hand I called on him
probably thinking it was a question
about the material or going to the
bathroom something like that and in a
straight face said
Joe Biden belongs in prison
and
it I just froze it just froze in the
classroom so
um
just an interesting experience I wanted
to share and maybe get your reaction uh
maybe get your uh
maybe explanation of why well listen my
I I don't know what age the student was
but my guess is
this is not something the student
learned in school but this is probably
something the student is hearing at home
and it's very very sad I mean listen
you come from a conservative family you
might say oh Joe Biden's position on
abortion doesn't align with my families
or whatever
um but Joe Biden belongs in prison
for what crime and that is one of those
signals when you hear that it's sort of
like when you would hear certain things
about said about Barack Obama where you
go that's not a policy disagreement
you've fallen for really serious
weaponized disinformation and it's a sad
thing that it's even hitting uh hitting
kids we've got a great bonus show for
you today we're going to talk about the
Supreme Court backing qualified immunity
for police officers really a big story
with far-reaching trickle-down
implications we will look at Democrats
eyeing a carbon tax a carbon tax after
Joe manchin's opposition to The Climate
plan and the reconciliation bill and we
are going to talk about how Joe Biden is
now trying to figure out how can he
quietly restart student loan payments
and uh why why quietly well I think you
can probably guess why we'll talk about
all of those stories on today's bonus
show get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com